oh
get bent i am a wolf therian and a
member of the furry fandom what a sin
do you have plans tonight
yeah i'm gonna hang out with friends are
they coming here i don't know yet you
guys left a disaster out there this is
the matt walsh video you left a [ __ ]
disaster no it didn't it's not okay
don't worry about it hey here you want
to do the intro for this video since i
don't know as much about match what
matters i don't know what's about matt
walsh i just know that he's a
conservative political commentator yeah
he works for the daily wire which is a
conservative news outlet well he made
his uh documentary called what is a
woman so i believe this is a snippet
from there i do think we should make a
whole video reacting to that that would
probably be pretty interesting what is a
woman what is that i don't know i've
been wanting to watch it i've been
hearing how great it is uh yes i would
love to react to that but yeah i mean
the [ __ ] left lunacy is absurd at
this point so let's just watch some of
it and give our thoughts finally we're
not watching some page [ __ ] yeah i love
tate but i need to take a break take
break before we get into it make sure
you like subscribe and join the discord
in my comments if you're a g quick sneak
peek from the film and this relates to
you know everything we talked about
really in the opening the it's sort of
the logical conclusion of the leftist
sexual
agenda what what happens when we become
unmoored from truth unworked from
reality
from our moral tradition
and we uh took the rabbit hole all the
way down in the film so i want to play
this clip from uh what is a woman which
is available now at what is woman.com
you can become a subscriber and watch
but here it is
so now we are seeing kids that are
identifying as animals going to school
and they are purring like that's the
thing like if you can be whatever you
want where where does it end because
they've proven that when they do this
[ __ ] they always take it too far
literally with everything they've done
like the transgender stuff they have men
playing in women's sports they're giving
kids hormones like where where does it
end because if you keep going down that
rabbit hole wouldn't it just be yeah i'm
an animal yeah i identify as a
eight-year-old boy like where where does
it end i heard two stories one of them
which i know is true and one of them
which i have not verified the unverified
one is that there's a kid these both
here in massachusetts there's one kid
who identifies as a bird and the parents
insisted that there's a
nest in the school for the kid to hang
out in when it needs to be a bird and
then the verified story is that another
kid which is what this woman is just
about to say uh identified as a cat
and the parents insisted that the school
and the teachers and the class everybody
play along and then one day the cat
scratched another little kid because
that's what cats do and then all of a
sudden everybody finally came to their
senses that oh you
can't do that little kit kat imagine i
can't imagine as a parent going to
school and insisting that everyone treat
you like a frog because you want to be a
frog this it's just it's just the
stupidest [ __ ] imagine imagine when
you're a little kid you need structure
in your life like imagine telling a
little kid that he could be a cat that
has nothing to do with structure but it
definitely does have to do with
structure when you raise me as a boy yes
you're a boy it gives you structure in
your life there's some there's some
stuff that needs to be norms in society
and the way the left has it is they have
it totally backwards they say that
there's no physical norms like a man can
be a woman woman can be a man all this
all this crazy [ __ ] and then that you
need to rely on the government when the
truth is there are physical norms and
you shouldn't rely on the government you
should only rely on yourself literally
only yourself and realize that the only
people that truly care about you are you
your boys and your family that's it but
they literally have it all completely
backwards right yeah they want the
government to do more and more i was
talking with somebody yesterday um about
a particular problem and she said the
government is the one that created it so
they need to be the one that fixes it
and i was like [ __ ] fix it yourself no
they they created it because they're
completely incompetent and you want to
give them more money and more power and
more time to create more problems it's
idiotic they're absolutely incompetent
and driven by ulterior motives to
continue to fight for putting our lives
in the hands of the government is a
death sentence no sen it makes no sense
at all it's the whole reason that
america exists because we wanted to not
be controlled by the english government
we wanted less government i feel like
that whole original idea of how this
country started was
we were being taxed but we had no
representation in parliament so you've
heard the expression taxation without
representation and i feel like that's
what we have now i feel like i just
especially here in massachusetts just
pouring and pouring and pouring money
into the government because they tax us
so much and getting and feeling
completely unrepresented
and now biden gave a what is it 300
billion dollar 300 billion dollars of
loan forgiveness on full grown-ass
people
because i went to the get [ __ ] done
university and i got [ __ ] done myself
what people choose to go into that debt
why why is that getting forgiven that's
so stupid with tax dollars now think
about the guy who is a you know a man a
laborer like sweeps floors you know
never had an opportunity to go to
college maybe because of family
circumstances or money or maybe he just
wasn't never smart enough to go to
college whatever who knows that guy now
has to contribute an extra what it comes
out to is about two thousand dollars a
year per taxpayer he for some for
somebody who wanted their gender studies
degree wanted their gender studies
degree from harvard who because they
have a harvard diploma is going to make
all kinds of money anyway but that
person needs needs his money drop dead
it's [ __ ] yeah it is and it's
serfdom it's modern-day serfdom for the
elites to stand on the necks of the
non-elites that's what it is because
they want people continuing to go into
college and get into that stupid [ __ ]
continue to get indoctrinated yeah and
they meow and
the teachers are not allowed to question
it because it's considered a queer
identity so
what
you have kids are going to school and
they're saying i'm a cat
and the teachers have to
affirm them as a cat
yes so it's not just
literal zoos now basically
[Laughter]
i am a 27 year old transgender woman
i am a wolf therian and a member of the
furry fandom when and how did you
discover this inner wolfeness um
probably around age 10 or 11. how do you
get this thing to do this interview that
is a grown man not a thing grown man
woman wolf it doesn't matter it's a
grown man who was also a wolf woman i
don't know listen whatever that wasn't
the point how do you how do you get this
creature to come into the studio and do
this interview well that's that i wish
matt walsh would answer that question
for us like we want to hear from your
producers and how they pulled this [ __ ]
off okay they pay them like what an
anime about wolves and
see the wolf running across the screen
and i'm somehow just intrinsically like
oh that's me have you spent any time
around biological goals yes that sounds
dangerous also what context are you so i
was a volunteer with the preserve and
i've also visited many wolf preserves
are you able to communicate
with the wolves am i going to have a
conversation with a wolf in the way that
i'm communicating you and i obviously
not am i going to read their body
language respond appropriately to their
behaviors and their nonverbal cues yes
would you would you be able to give us
anybody can do that anybody that studies
wolves and wolf behavior could do that
so that's okay so
go ahead please i am dying to know what
you have to think don't tell me you want
to be a [ __ ] wolf though mom i have
something to tell you
i identify as a chili dog yeah i don't
think anybody identifies as a chili dog
yet but i'll be the first i'm sure
there's a club of people that already do
because there's something for everybody
out there if not we'll start it i hate
this video this wolf communication um no
i'm not comfortable doing so okay all
right
i mean i thought i'd ask anyone
uh i would be interested to know i mean
i i still would would like to know what
um
really what the interpersonal
communication between a wolf is like
when you see that and you think well
that's uh absurd and you can kind of
laugh about it and sure but
you know i'm telling you right now this
is not uh
this is not any kind of
um extreme slippery slope
possibility i think that
a few years from now that someone i
don't know if it's gonna be me but
someone's gonna have to make a film
called what is a human because
this trans species stuff this is not
um just a fringe
fad
you know outlier type of thing
this as we heard from sarah stockton
who's the therapist in the first part of
that clip
this is a very common thing
and she's not the only one saying
i wouldn't say it's very common but you
know we hear people that work in the
schools two therapists that feel like
they can speak out without being having
their careers destroyed
this is this is the thing now we don't
know yet kids this is what kids are
doing
and it's like well and of course kids
are doing that
when you tell kids that hey you could be
whatever you want to be
your identity is up to you i would have
been indiana jones when i was little i'd
love that that would be cool yeah i
would have been some cool [ __ ] though i
wouldn't have been a cat or some dumb
stuff i would have been something dope a
wolf with the turquoise hair
if you could be anything when you're
little what would you have been i was
probably thinking i was going to be a
dancer you would be a dancer yeah oh
yeah i wanted to be a carpenter and
grandma said no imagine you were
actually a carpenter and you had to bust
your ass every day going and if i was a
carpenter maybe i'd have my own show on
hgtv just
hammering nails into [ __ ] for money big
money never know she said girls couldn't
be carpenters she was old-fashioned what
are you gonna do kids
pretending to be animals as long as
they're kids now the person we were
talking to there the was it wolf therian
not a kid that's an adult but for kids
pretending to be animals usually it's uh
my own kids do that sometimes
my two-year-old runs around pretending
to be them and that's that's perfectly
fine that's using your imagination
except that we don't live in a sane
society and so now uh we latch on to
that and say okay well that that's your
right that's who you are now that's your
identity
who lets a little kid take on an
identity of being a cat to the point
where that kid can no longer communicate
as a human being or refuses to
communicate as a human being if you
pulled that [ __ ] and i was talking to
you and you were just going me out yeah
help me out for weeks on end [ __ ]
first of all yeah you would have been
slapped okay sorry not advocating child
abuse calm down but you know what
everyone needs a slap once in a while
kids eating bleach under the sink slap
it meowing at ya yeah and then if it
didn't work i would have brought you to
the looney bin you would have brought me
up to that farm and you would say the
farm we're yeah they're free little boys
we have the farm where we bring the the
cats that don't behave in dogs you're
free now did you see an um i mean what
the actual [ __ ] are these parents
thinking they're thinking that they're
making these kids giving them good
social skills good health life is hard
enough life is hard for every human
being that comes onto this planet some
have it harder than others we know but
you're gonna actually go and take a
child and go you know what honey i'm
gonna make it even harder for you i'm
gonna make you the biggest [ __ ]
weirdo this town has ever seen i'm gonna
do that for you and make sure that
you're ostracized forever just to prove
a point about how everyone should be
accepted get bent these people what a
sin
i bet i wonder if by the end of our
lives it'll have to be you accept
someone as an animal i genuinely i'm not
i'm not hiring any [ __ ] animals at my
company i'm sorry i i need people that
can talk human but howl when they answer
the phone you're pretty you're pretty
racist for that one no that's you're
racist species you're racist and sexist
speciesist no or is it speciesist do you
know what you are you'll be the [ __ ]
that's where you are your bees are [ __ ]
what are you gonna do all right well
that was a quick one thank you guys so
much for watching remember to like
subscribe and join the discord in my bio
say something funny
[Music]
won't last long